>>> CALIFORNIA CAN GOVERNOR
GAVIN NEWSOM ISSUING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AS A MAJOR OIL SPILL
THREATENS THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COASTLINE.
CREWS MOVING TO TAKE CARE OF THE
DISASTER.
AS MUCH AS 144,000 GALLONS OF
OIL MAY HAVE LEAKED INTO THE
PACIFIC OCEAN.
THAT'S THE LATEST UNDERSTANDING.
AND NOW THERE ARE NEW QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHEN THE LEAK FIRST
STARTED.
WHY IT TOOK SO LONG TO RESPOND.
CNN'S CAMILA BERNAL IS IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH WITH MORE.
WHAT ARE YOU LEARNING TODAY?
>> Reporter: HEY, KATE, HERE THE
THING.
LOCAL OFFICIALS AND RESIDENTS
ARE REALLY DEMANDING ANSWERS.
AND IT IS BECAUSE WE REVIEWED
SOME DOCUMENTS AND THEY SHOW
THAT THERE WERE REPORTS OF AN
OIL SHEEN ON FRIDAY NIGHT.
THAT'S MORE THAN 12 HOURS BEFORE
THE COMPANY AMPLIFY ENERGY,
REPORTED THIS SPILL.
NOW, THEY SAY THEIR WORKERS
FOUND OUT ON SATURDAY MORNING.
AND THAT'S WHEN THEY REPORTED IT
TO STATE AND FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES.
THEY ALSO SAY THAT THEY HAVE
DEVICES IN PLACE THAT WILL TELL
YOU THERE'S A LEAK.
EVEN IF YOU DON'T SEE THE OIL.
BUT THEY SAY THEY DIDN'T GET ANY
NOTIFICATIONS.
PEOPLE HERE ARE UPSET, THEY WANT
TO KNOW EXACTLY WHEN THIS
HAPPENED.
HOW IT HAPPENED AND WHY.
AMPLIFY ENERGY MAY SAY IT'S
POSSIBLE IT'S FROM AN ANCHOR
FROM ONE OF THE SHIPS GOING BY
THAT CAUSED THIS.
BUT THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY IN
ORANGE COUNTY SAYS THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH.
THEY WANT AN EXPLANATION BECAUSE
THERE'S STILL A LOT OF WORK TO
BE DONE HERE, KATE, AND IT'S NOT
AN EASY CLEANUP.
>> CAMILLA, THANK YOU FOR THAT.
LET'S GET TO MORE OF THIS,
JOINING ME IS KATRINA FOLEY,
SHE'S A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS REPRESENTING
HUNTINGTON BEACH.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT KATRINA IS
SAYING.
THERE IS A REAL DISCONNECT AND
REAL CONCERN NOW ABOUT WHEN THE
COMPANY KNEW OF A PROBLEM, WHEN
IT WAS REPORTED AND WHEN ACTION
WAS TAKEN.
WHAT IS YOUR UNDERSTANDING AND
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING?
>> WELL, THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
TODAY.
THIS IS QUITE DEVASTATING
SITUATION HERE IN ORANGE COUNTY.
IT'S GONE FROM HUNTINGTON BEACH
ALL THE WAY TO DANA POINT NOW.
IT'S HITTING THE ENTIRE ORANGE
COUNTY COAST.
AND WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT THE
LEAK STARTED ON FRIDAY.
AND THERE WAS CALLS FROM EITHER
BOATERS OR THE PLATFORM WORKERS
THEMSELVES.
TO LET SOMEONE KNOW TO COME OUT
AND CHECK THE LEAK.
SO, I DO THINK THAT WE NEED TO
START INVESTIGATING WHEN THOSE
CALLS OCCURRED.
AND WHO MADE THOSE CALLS.
AND THERE -- I WANT TO POINT
OUT, SO, THERE'S VERY LEGAL
TERMS, VERY SPECIFIC LEGAL
TERMS, THAT ARE BEING USED HERE,
THAT ARE DIFFERENT FOR NOTIFYING
PURPOSES, THAN LIKE YOU AND I
MIGHT THINK OF NOTICE.
I THINK OF NOTICE AS THEY CALLED
THEM.
THEY SAID THERE'S A LEAK.
THE NOTICE REQUIREMENT, UNDER
THE LAW IS SOMETHING SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT.
AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK THE
COMPANY IS HANGING THEIR HAT ON
RIGHT NOW, SAYING THEY DIDN'T
HAVE NOTICE UNTIL SATURDAY.
>> AND MISS FOLEY, WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT?
BECAUSE, OBVIOUSLY, IF WE'RE
BEING REALLY HONEST, MINUTES AND
HOURS MATTER WHEN YOU'VE GOT
GALLONS OF OIL LEAKING INTO THE
OCEAN.
>> 100%.
IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE LEAK
CONTINUED TO POUR OIL INTO THE
OCEAN, WHICH CONTINUED TO FLOW
TOWARDS ORANGE COUNTY.
AND WHAT WAS REALLY CRITICAL IS
THAT, ON SATURDAY, THERE WERE
HUNDREDS OF BOATERS OUT ON THE
HUNTINGTON BEACH COAST BECAUSE
WE HAD THE AIR SHOW GOING ON.
THERE WERE HUNDREDS OF BOATERS
COMING BACK AND FORTH FROM
CATALINA TO ORANGE COUNTY.
AND SO, ALL OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
WERE IMPACTED.
AND IT ALSO CAUSED US TO LOSE
TIME TO BE ABLE TO PUT UP
BARRIERS TO PROTECT OUR
WETLANDS, AND TO PROTECT THOSE
AREAS THAT WE'VE WORKED SO HARD
TO BRING BACK, AFTER THE LAST
OIL SPILL.
SO IT'S REALLY, REALLY
DISAPPOINTING.
>> AND ALSO, ON TOP OF THIS, THE
EXACT CAUSE OF THE LEAK REMAINS
UNCLEAR AT THIS MOMENT.
HOW IMPORTANT IS GETTING THAT
ANSWER FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE?
>> WELL, I THINK ALL OF THESE
QUESTIONS ARE SUPER IMPORTANT.
AND WE WILL GET THE ANSWERS.
THE CAUSE OF THE LEAK, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT FROM THE PRESS
BRIEFING YESTERDAY, THEY MAY
MAYBE IDENTIFIED WHERE ON THE
PIPELINE THE LEAK IS CAUSED.
I'M NOT BUYING AT THIS POINT
THAT IT WAS AN ANCHOR FROM A
TANKER.
THERE IS PLENTY OF GPS SYSTEMS.
BUT MAYBE IT WAS.
I DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S FOR THE EXPERTS AND THE
INDEPENDENT EXPERTS TO
DETERMINE.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK IS
VERY IMPORTANT.
I KNOW OTHERS DO AS WELL.
THAT IT MUST BE AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION.
WE CAN'T RELY ON THE COMPANY'S
INVESTIGATORS TO TELL US WHAT
HAPPENED, BECAUSE, OBVIOUSLY,
THEY ARE BIASED.
>> KATRINA FOLEY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I KNOW THIS IS DEVASTATING.
NOT ONLY FOR THE WILDLIFE, BUT
DEVASTATING TO THE COMMUNITY AND
THE ECONOMY THE LONGER THAT THE
BEACHES